notre gouvernement est très fier d'avoir
contribué à la réalisation de cette
infrastructure économique majeure nous
croyons que le gouvernement fédéral peut
et doit jouer un rôle positif pour
appuyer les efforts du Québec et aider
les Québécois à conserver cet acquis
social si important je veux changer la
façon dont nous faisons de la politique
dans ce pays
alors cette semaine les chefs des trois
principaux partis nous ont donné un
avantgoût de la campagne électorale
fédérale on est encore à un an des
élections mais c'est un peu la réalité
des élections à date fixe alors de
belles images des engagements et même on
vient le voir une promesse du NPD donc
sur un programme de garderie alors
Daniel est ce soir à cherbrook pour son
autre carrière de romantié bonsoir
Daniel bonsoir et avec moi en studio
Michel et tacha bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir bonsoir alors c'est les
élections mulker qui fait une première
promesse tacha est-ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie de dévoiler ces cartes
comme ça à 1 an quand même des élections
euh je pense que oui ironiquement c'est
la même stratégie que Mike Haris avait
en Ontario avec le common sense
Revolution c'était en 95 et c'est une
façon de coincer les adversaires les
forcer de les sortir et maintenant on
voit que ce qu'il fait monsieur mker
c'est intelligent parce que il fait une
polarisation politique qui coince les
libéraux dans dans le milieu c'est la
même chose qui s'est fait en 2011 avec
les conservateurs d'un bar les n plus
de gauche et comme ça les libéraux ici
quel quel est le terrain qui peuvent
occuper sur cette promesse là c'est très
difficile de voir alors je pense c'est
un pas très intelligent de sa part oui
Michel oui je pense que c'est c'est très
bon d'abord on sait pas quand est-ce que
les élections vont avoir lieu c'est
peut-être dans 6 mois tout à fait alors
est jamais trop tôt pour bien faire
monsieur mker a dit lui-même je pense il
y a un mois qui s'était point inspiré de
Monsieur Harris mais de Jean char
l'épù
luiur é par libéral Québec souvenez-vous
en sept 2002 ma mémoire est bonne
monsieur char on savait pas quand les
élections étaient pour avoir lieu avait
dévoilé l'essentiel de son programme
pourquoi parce que comme dans le cas de
Monsieur molker il y avait du rattrapage
à faire à l'époque c'était face au à
laadq les libéraux étaient 3è dans les
sondages monsieur molker est un peu dans
la même situation et il fallait je pense
qu'il se dépêche là à incruster dans
esprit des électeurs les principaux
thèmes qui est à la tête ce de sa
campagne et dans le cas qui nous occupe
je pense qu' là il fait une belle
démonstration de ce que pourrait être un
gouvernement progressiste alors que
Monsieur Trudeau lui est encore dans la
les vœux pieux je dans les généralité
Daniel mais est-ce que c'est pas un
Paris quand même un peu risqué parce que
ça bon les élections peuvent être
devancé c'est vrai mais si elles ont lu
dans un an c'est quand même long il va
falloir qu'il vend cette cette politique
là ouais ça sera pas nécessairement
facile à vendre comme on l'a vu dans
reportage de Denis Martin il y a
quelques instants euh ces deux gros
morceaux on l'oublie parfois que que que
que Thomas mulk remis sur la table il a
aussi le salaire minimum à 15 dollars
c'est un très gros morceau très grosse
promesse électorale avec les garderies
il joue très gros mais je suis d'accord
avec mes deux collègues il faut qu'il le
fasse maintenant malgré une performance
très intéressante certains diront
exceptionnel en Chambre des communes les
Canadiennes arrivent toujours pas à
tomber en amour avec Taman mulker donc
il doit porter des grands coups
maintenant pour attirer leur attention
est-ce que c'est
j'écoutais une porte-parole des
conservateurs candis Bergen pour ne pas
la nommer qui disait c'est un très
mauvais projet on a vu des projets
semblables qui fonctionnent pas
évidemment fais allusion au Québec
monsieur ce que Monsieur mol veut faire
c'est d'élever lui-même nos enfants ça
c'est de la rétorique partisan on va en
entendre beaucoup là où j'ai des
problèmes ou peut-être des inquiétudes
pour Monsieur molker est-ce que c'est
vendable est-ce que les provinces vont
suivre le Québec bien sûr parce que bon
il a déjà son programme il fonctionne
bien mais ailleurs en Alberta en
ontariocomie britannique est-ce qu'on va
suivre je suis loin d'être convaincu et
si les provinces se suivent pas son
programme il va nulle part hein mais par
rapport au conservateurs en tout cas la
stratégie est assez claire la la la
différence entre les politiques fiscales
des conservateurs et ce que propose
monsieur mulker est très évident quand
on parle de de deux visions du pays
absolument et c'est choix clair c'est ça
ce qui coince les libéraux parce que
effectivement l' NPD pique le programme
l'ancien programme des libéraux sur les
garderies alors ça laisse quelle sorte
de terrain à jouer aussi si on voit ce
que Monsieur a fait s'opposant très
clairement à la participation canadienne
dans la guerre contre l'ISIL euh c'est
que une façon aussi de se démarquer et
Monsieur Trudeau avait l'air un peu mou
sur la question alors déjà il il tranche
pour l' NPD ils sont de gauche ils sont
progressistes les conservateurs sont en
faveur du choix dans la famille donneent
l'argent directement aux familles
potentiellement le partage de revenus
aussi de la famille alors c'est c'est
vraiment une façon de de camper
idéologiquement mais Daniel justement on
parlait de Monsieur Trudeau qui arrive à
Québec qui fait un discours où il reste
encore une fois très général il donne sa
vision un peu de ce qu'il voudrait du
fédéralistme la place du Québec mais
c'est assez général on est loin encore
de savoir ce qu'il va y avoir dans sa
plateforme électorale et et ça on
l'explique vous l'interprétez comment
bah écoutez euh il y avait un élément
intéressant dans son discours qui m'a
fait sourire vous avez raison sur le
fond on cherche toujours où il s'en va
il y avait un élément intéressant en
disant moi je veux donner aux Québécois
une bonne place à Otawa 1967 de pierreot
Trudeau son père disait exactement la
même chose i s ané gérarder les trois
colonses de jeanmarchand par la suite
Marc lond Jean-Chrétien ils ont fait des
choses on est d'accord ou on est pas
d'accord là n'est pas la question ils
ont fait des choses les Québécois
étaient extrêmement présents à Otawa
c'est pas le cas en ce moment tant dans
les rangs du gouvernement des
conservateurs que de l'opposition je
n'ai jamais vu en 30 ans de de de de
couverture politique à Otawa un groupe
de députés québécois aussi ai peu
présent aussi faible que celui qui est
là en ce moment s'il réussit à changer
ça tant mieux mais pour attirer ces gens
il on il ont n murmur aux oreilles qu'
il y a plein de gros candidats qui vont
suivre Justin Trudeau il va falloir
qu'on leur donne quelque chose à manger
quelque chose à vendre quelque chose de
précis de solide comme Thomas mulker
vient de le faire et pour l'instant ces
gens-là c'est quoi le programme libéral
où il s'en va Justin Rudeau on ne sait
pas mais mais c'est intéressant parce
que Daniel a raison de le souligner
faire une plus grande place aux
Québécois à atawa mais ça ça veut pas
dire faire une plus grande place au
Québec dans la Fédération et la réalité
de la Fédération c'est que les
québeécois sont de moins en moins
nombreux et ont de moins en moins de
poids à cause de la démographie c'est
même pas de la mauvaise volonté et pour
ça monsieur Trudeau ne promet
strictement rien il ne veut pas rouvrir
la Constitution alors à partir du moment
où il ne veut pas un reconnaître
officiellement la différence et
transposer ça concrètement dans un
nouveau partage des pouvoirs ou la façon
dont on voudra ça ne veut strictement
rien dire si c'est pour favoriser la
carrière d'un certain nombre de de
Québécois c'est bien intéressant pour
eux mais pour l'ensemble des Québécois
ça ne présente pas un grand intérêt la
ch ça vous fait sourire mais comment
est-ce qu'il est perçu dans le reste du
Canada parce qu'on regarde dans toutes
les dernières élections provinciales ce
sont des gouvernements libéraux qui ont
été élus au nouveau Bronswick monsieur
trudau la présence de Monsieur troudeau
a joué en faveur des libéraux al c'est
sûr qu'il est très populaire écoutez les
sondages malgré une certaine petite
dégringolade de cette semaine monsieur
trud à cause de tout ce débat sur l'IRAC
exactement monsieur Trudeau est très
populaire et c'est sa personne plus que
c'est politiques qu'il vend et le
problème je pense que c'est il doit
mettre de la chair sur l'os il l'a pas
fait et Monsieur M maintenant est en
train de le faire alors le reste du
Canada peut-être un peu en amour avec sa
personnalité il va sortir un livre
bientôt il a une P aussi question de sa
personnalité oui para dans Chatelain sa
famille qui binene dans la piscine en
tout cas c'est c'est très cute mais
est-ce que c'est assez je pense qu'à un
moment donné même le Canada anglais va
voir ve vousou voir plus oui alors ce
livre est-ce que ça peut changer les
choses mich Dani en un mot euh en un mot
non euh parce que
parce parce que parce que parce que dans
un an le livre sera très très loin sur
les palmarès du livre et deuxièmement le
véritable livre que les gens veulent
lire c'est un livre comme disait l'autre
sur les vrais affaires sur les vrais
ouais tout à fait je comprends qu'au
Québec monsieur Trudeau a un nom
populaire et que c'est c'est un gentil
garçon mais je pense que l'intérêt réel
de de sa de sa présence éventuellement
pour les Québécois ça va être de voir
dans quel mesure il peut lui permettre
au Québec ou au Canada de se débarrasser
des conservateurs je pense je pense
qu'éventuellement ça va être ça est-ce
que c'est le NPD ou est-ce que c'est les
libéraux qui vont permettre de battre
les
conservateurs pour le reste ce sont des
questions qui je pense vont être assez
secondaires dans l'esprit des électeurs
québécois tout le moins je veux pas
partir pour le reste du pays mais au
Québec c'est comme ça je pense que
l'analyse va être faite mais quand même
si je peux ajouter je pense que le fait
que Monsieur sorti la politique sur les
garderies en particulier c'est pour
faire appel à l'électorat québécois non
seulement pour faire sortir monsieur
Harper mais faire appel avec un
programme qui est très cher au aux
Québécois en particulier ouis un
programme et qui va être financièrement
très intéressant siis finance à hauteur
de 60 % les garderies et vous savez 60 %
de 2.2 milliards ça aiderait déjà
beaucoup à régler le problème budgétaire
exement bon parlons un peu de STEP
Harper parce qu'il était lui aussi au
Québec cette semaine en précampagne et
il est il a voulu se rapprocher de de
Philippe Couillard sur le pétrole
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter ce
geste Michel bah d'abord ça coûte pas
grand-chose à monsieur Harper ça coûte
en fait strictement rien d'autre part je
pense que monsieur Harper même si dans
mon esprit en tout cas a pas grand
espoir électoraux au Québec il faut
quand même qu'il donne l'impression de
bien s'entendre avec le gouvernement du
Québec faut pas qu'il apparaisse comme
un facteur de division du pays aux yeux
de l'électorat à l'extérieur du Québec
alors maintenant euh cette question là
c'était une demande du Québec mais
maintenant il faut bien se dire que
c'est ce qu'on appellerait une long shot
en bon français on sait pas si combien
il y a de pétrole si est exploitable
quels sont les risques pour
l'environnement si éventuellement ça
devient rentable pour les Québécois et
l'État québécois c'est à long terme à
court terme la promesse de monsieur
molker est bien plus intéressante et et
son autre promesse par exemple de de
rétablir les transferts en santé euh au
niveau où ils le sont actuellement alors
que les conservateurs veulent simplement
l'indexer à la hausse de de l'économie
oui c'est beaucoup plus intéressant pour
le gouvernement du Québec d' ben je
pense aussi qu'il veut avoir Mons
Couillard dans son coin et il va lui
donner le respect dans un sens comme
comme tu dis Michel qui qui l' dû
c'est-à-dire venir au Québec faire cet
annonce démontrer l'intérêt même s'il y
a pas tant de votes que les
conservateurs peuvent chercher et aussi
ça rapproche un peu la culture
pétrolière de l'Ouest avec l'EST
c'est-à-dire le pétrole c'est pas
seulement une affaire albertaine c'est
aussi le Québec alors peut-être ça a si
Québec peut devenir une province SLE ça
va régler un certain nombre de problèmes
pour monsur un Daniel est-ce que le
Québec va être un enjeu parce que quand
même on a vu il a pris de la place cette
semaine ils étaient ici on en a parlé
est-ce que ça va être un enjeu dans
cette campagne électorale même si même
si des conservateur et stevenen Harper
ont fait la preuve la dernière fois
qu'ils peuvent gagner et être
majoritaire sans le Québec le Québec est
toujours important on peut pas faire une
élection fédérale en se disant bon on se
préoccupe pas du Québec même Stephen
Harper il sait très bien qu'il va pas
qu'il aura pas une Harper manie au
Québec il sait très bien qu'il fera pas
élire 50 députés s'il pouvait en faire
élire 10 et trouver deux ou trois gros
joueurs on parle de Laurence canon qui
reviendrait capable de renflouer son
équipe il serait très heureux il a pas
renoncé au Québec mais il est aussi très
réaliste et et dans le cas du pétrole et
dans le cas de Philippe Couillard plus
grand danger pour Monsieur Couillard
c'est que bon les Québécois ont beaucoup
diabolisé Stepen harperard ou à raison
mais l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
il ne l'aime pas c'est à cause de
l'environnement ils ont carrément
l'impression et ils ont pas tard que que
Harper se fout carrément de
l'environnement que pour lui il a que le
développement économique pour Philippe
Couillard de se coller comme ça Steven
Harper pas certain moi que c'est un bon
Paris et et je CIS certain que Monsieur
couard a très envie actuellement là
d'ajouter ce dossier là à au déjà au
contentieux sur kakuna and bridge et
cetera je pense la cour est pleine de
pétrole pour le moment en ce qui
concerne monsieur Couillard alors on
aura le temps de s'en reparler si c'est
dans un an c'est plutôt an dans un an
merci beaucoup à vous trois auir ou
c'est revir au revoir bye bye merci
beaucoup